the fourth of July is still six weeks
away but given the challenges that we
face today a reminder of why we
celebrate we hold these truths to be now
earlier today a good friend of mine and
I were talking about how surprising it
was that so many Americans were willing
to give up their inalienable rights for
a government promise of safety basic
liberties the right to work to travel to
worship free speech the right to attend
school to petition the government to
assemble with others they all were
completely sidelined or partially
sidelined during the Cova 19 shutdowns
officials assured us that restrictions
would be short-lived and only be in
place until we flatten the curve but
even after we did that in hospitals
thankfully were not overrun blue state
governors began piling on new conditions
in order to for states to be fully
reopened again they had complicated
requirements in a new york of the 51
page reopening document Michigan then
Illinois and Washington state they
seemed hell-bent on keeping people in
mobile and scared as long as possible
and now they found a new excuse for
delay the need for hundreds of thousands
of so-called
contact tracers the point of this is to
create a corps of trained folks who are
ready and able have the skills we need
them to have to help usher us all
through the the new environment I know a
lot of you don't answer the phone when
you see an unknown caller reaching in
but I implore you to answer that call we
want to grow our voluntary contact
tracing so that we can further control
and reduce the rate of spread of kovat
19 and stop outbreaks in their tracks
yeah I trust him well what TSA was to
Poe
the post 9/11 era contact tracing is to
the Cova Dara it's all for our own good
and protection that's what they say and
it seems fine at first until maybe like
when you're in talking about TSA an
agent's hand gets a little too close to
your private parts during a random
screening and then they throw away your
favorite moisturizer right because it's
too many ounces but at least your
interaction with a TSA agent is brief
and limited to only when you fly your
interaction with a kovat tracer could
last for weeks if not longer according
to the AP the practice of so-called
contact tracing requires a hybrid job of
interrogator therapist and nurse as they
try to coax nervous people to be honest
the goal to create a road map of
everywhere infected people have been and
who they've been around
that's a heavy lift so how many of these
tracers will we actually need health
investigator McKenzie Bray follows a
script that she knows all too well I'm
just following up on your coded banking
test results Bray is among an army of
health professionals and volunteers of
working as contact tracers some health
officials estimate that as many as
300,000 contact tracers would be needed
in the country to effectively mitigate
the spread are you kidding me
300,000 so I remember I talked about how
this kind of reminds me of the TSA their
creation of the TSA well if the quote
experts get their way there will be six
times more contact tracers than TSA
agents but instead of rummaging through
your luggage these contact tracers will
be prying into the most intimate details
of your life if you're found to have
been in the orbit of someone who tested
positive for the virus they could
monitor your whereabouts continuously
until they determine you're no longer a
danger to others now right now it may be
only for 14 days or so but what happens
when the next expert tells us something
different maybe next week what about
your medical information it's very
personal to you well according to the
tracer training
program run by Johns Hopkins University
that we had a producer actually sign up
for today it's required for tracers
hired in New York your medical
information will be kept confidential
they say though perhaps not all of it
this is how one slide and that training
program puts it your medical information
cannot be shared with anyone else unless
you agree to it but York Ovid 19 test
results can be shared to protect public
health well why is that well according
to Johns Hopkins it's because quote
contact tracing programs are a public
good they can reduce illness and deaths
from kovat 19 a public good again it
sounds fine very reasonable but I
thought in a representative democracy
the people get to determine what is in
the quote public good not unaccountable
experts at a university that receives
millions of dollars in grant money from
billionaires and corporate foundations
given the enormity of the federal
in-state expenditures we're talking
about here it's amazing how little
debate there's been about the risk to
personal privacy I'm telling you there
are always going to be plenty of reasons
cited by government bureaucrats or
unelected technocrats to justify taking
your freedoms away they'll cite scary
things it's like gun violence climate
change and now of course Kovac maybe the
next virus and they'll use our fear and
maybe even skews statistics or bad
modeling to manipulate the public
perception they'll find experts who
insist that the harm to personal privacy
is minimal and that any trade-off is
worth it they'll promise their actions
will be temporary and narrowly tailored
but invariably these new programs like
what we saw after 9/11 will become
permanent fixtures in American life and
end up expanding far beyond their
promised goals I think back of the
creation of the FISA Court the Patriot
Act just to name a few
next thing you know bad actors use them
as weapons against innocent
people and they almost managed to undo a
presidential election the government can
use a variety of tools to enforce its
new normal using self-assessment tools
is the least concerning I think from my
personal privacy standpoint but then
there are these location devices using a
variety of technological tools to
monitor you yesterday Google and Apple
unveiled the phone app that lets you
know when you've been exposed to someone
who's kovat positive in 22 countries
have already signed on to use the app
now the tech giant's did craft this app
with user privacy and minds we'll give
them a thumbs up for that but according
to The Wall Street Journal the entire
purpose of the app is to quote help
Public Health Department's track contact
between strangers personally I'd take
whatever privacy promises though that
some of these companies are making today
with a grain of salt
the fact is tracking technology can have
a terrible chilling effect on individual
freedom and even expression the Supreme
Court noted this a few years ago in its
landmark ruling to enforce location data
protections the court in carpenter
versus the United States said detailed
travel and location data provides an
intimate window into a person's life
revealing not only his particular
movements but through them his familial
political professional religious and
sexual associations and remember those
seemingly helpful Cova tracking apps are
themselves windows into your life
servers could be hacked data stolen and
generally the data is available
ultimately to anyone for theft or
purchase advertisers cyber criminals
even political adversaries and so on so
can the government federal or state
really ensure that our data not be
accessible to any of the above of course
the answer is no you'd be naive to think
otherwise they could perhaps mandate
though that the health information only
be available to health authorities but
given how wrong so many of their health
experts have been lately you really
can't blame them
Americans who have severe reservations
about trusting them with their private
medical information back to our
declaration our framers were really
smart Thomas Jefferson used that word
inalienable to describe our rights for a
reason Americans are born free we don't
get our rights from the government and
the government can never take them away
the government may sometimes force us to
make sacrifices but not indefinitely and
not without a serious debate over what
is in fact absolutely necessary to
preserve the lives of others today too
many officials are forgetting those
basic facts and that's the angle